hi i'm nino cater CEO spark digital
today we're gonna talk about NFC
otherwise known as near-field
communications basically what it is it's
a chip embedded in a smart phone that
corresponds with another chip embedded
in that credit card terminal so they
communicate with each other wirelessly
in a field that's only about ten
centimeters apart so it has to be really
mirror and it doesn't use a lot of power
they want to be able to convince a lot
of retailers grocery stores the Walmarts
of the world to adopt this and then
you're going to start seeing it more and
more
we could see NFC in a variety of
different places public transportation
at airport check-in you can even have
smart locks at your home that you can
use and open with your phone instead of
a set of keys so Apple's working with
the major credit card companies to set
up a secure standard that they're all
comfortable with for broadcasting your
credit card numbers in the air I think
it could be the future as we see more
and more people just using their phone
instead of carrying around a wallet and
eventually it might be powered by
Bitcoin subscribe on YouTube follow us
on Twitter and like us on Facebook